bom imagine que no futuro quando você
chegar em um supermercado para comprar
alimentos e não vou escolher só pelo
preço nem pela qualidade nutricional
desses alimentos mas se eles vão também
poder escolher pela história desse
alimento
vocês vão chegar no supermercado tirar o
iphone do bolso abrir o aplicativo mais
fundo clicar a tirar uma foto do que
acorde daquela embalagem ea no
aplicativo vai abrir dois links o
primeiro do google earth onde vai
mostrar onde está a fazenda onde aquele
alimento foi produzido e um segundo no
youtube que vai contar como aquele
alimento foi produzido como foi feito o
preparo do solo como foi feito o plantio
como foi feita a colheita quem foram as
pessoas responsáveis por aquilo ou a
empresa que foi responsável por aquilo
você ainda tiver uma versão paga do
aplicativo my futuro você vai conseguir
ainda fazer o tracking de todo o roteiro
dele saindo da fazenda
chegando no supermercado passando pela
agroindústria e chegando no supermercado
essa realidade esse futuro que parece
distante de conectar a produção com
consumo ele não é novidade no mundo na
austrália já têm iniciativas desse porte
é europa com identidade de origem
principalmente pra queijo vinho
champanhe canadá gente já tem coisa
desse tipo estados unidos e brasil mas
isso essa essa importância de você
contar boas histórias pra conectar a
produção com o consumo isso nasceu faz
muito tempo
a primeira pessoa o primeiro ser humano
a pensar nisso foi o homo sapiens lá
cerca de 150 mil anos antes de cristo
imagina o homo sapiens como o nome já
diz é uma espécie mais sapiente mais
inteligente que o anterior e ele
percebeu a importância disso muito cedo
imagina rotina desse cara ele saía de
manhã na caverna
passava o dia inteiro atrás de um bicho
para caçar tinha que correr atrás do
bicho acertar uma lança e ainda voltar
pra casa carregando o bicho nas costas
quando era um animal de pequeno porte
não tinha muito problema imagine quando
ele caçava um antílope ela passava o dia
inteiro tinha que correr mais acertar
lança com maior precisão e ainda sai
arrastando um bicho de 200 e 300 quilos
ele chegava na na caverna com bicho lá
arrastando a caverna toda escura ele
falava amor trouxe um antílope pra gente
comer que era a primeira coisa que ela
respondia já passaram duas horas e está
com cheiro de ena sempre foi assim isso
na humanidade sempre foi assim e ele
percebeu a importância que tinha que
solucionar essa divergência o que o
mossad em fez ele descobriu o pelo menos
dominou fogo
o fogo criou 3 é tv três coisas muito
importantes para ele a primeira a mulher
conseguia visualizar o alimento
a segunda ele consiga se proteger do
frio lembra que naquela época a gente
ainda estava no período de glaciação
muito forte ea terceira e se eu mostrar
que conseguia fazer churrasco e chamar
todos os outros como os hábeis para
contar essa história de caça e fazer
essa conexão encurtar esse caminho entre
oferta e demanda homosapiens ficou cerca
de 120 mil anos 130 mil anos nessa
rotina chata de sair caçando s strup a
ter que carregar o bicho nas costas
andar mudar de lugar sairá a áfrica ea
europa fazer churrasco lá e para as
américas e isso foi ficando muito
tedioso até que deus ou sabe se lá quem
é o regente na na época resolveu acabar
com o período de glaciação então ele o
as geleiras se derreteriam o mundo virou
uma superfície 70 e 80% de água o solo
começou a se aquecer ea neve virou chuva
esse
três fatores que possibilitaram a maior
invenção da humanidade até hoje que a
agricultura agricultura surgiu há cerca
de 10 mil anos antes de cristo na
mesopotâmia antigo oriente médio por um
grupo de mulheres
essas mulheres observarão que ao pegar
grãos de trigo fazendo um buraco no chão
replantando isso eles perceberam que
depois de um tempo e se essa planta
crescia novamente e produzir grãos em
uma quantidade de alimento muito maior
do que é sair para caçar
isso aconteceu em concomitância em
outros lugares do mundo na índia tem
indícios de 8 mi 8 e 6 mil anos antes de
cristo ásia 7 meio europa seis e meio e
aqui na américa 556 mil anos antes de
cristo
a agricultura teve um impacto enorme
nisso que eu falei de unir a oferta de
alimento com a demanda de alimentos
imagine que você deixou de ser nômade
você agora tinha um local se podia
produzir esse alimento e daí agricultura
possibilitou você a se organizar em
vilas essas vilas depois deram origem a
povoados e o que a gente tem hoje como
grandes cidades
a agricultura teve até esse momento que
eu falei um efeito de causa e evolução
da humanidade um efeito era consequência
disso então elas têm uma forte
correlação mas a agricultura era a causa
e evolução da humanidade a consequência
hoje esse papel se inverteu então essa
via mudou de mão para a gente entender
um pouco então para onde caminha a
agricultura a gente tem que falar um
pouco do seu sorologia a sociologia que
estuda os indivíduos e como eles se
relacionam ela divide essa história
recente da da humanidade em gerações
a primeira geração que é importante é
que teve um impacto significativo na
geração dos baby boomers que são os
nascidos entre 40 e 60 essa geração é a
geração que foi responsável pela
reconstrução
1o construção do mundo que que a gente
tem hoje eles nasceram pós-guerra
tiveram que reconstruir todo o mundo
os baby boomers fizeram essa
reconstrução sem pensar muito no futuro
eles não era uma geração preocupada com
o meio ambiente com o futuro da
humanidade eles tinham duas preocupações
trabalhar e ganhar dinheiro era essa
preocupação na época quem começa a
questionar esse modelo é a geração
seguinte
a geração x a geração x é uma geração
mais culta uma geração mais estudada
multicultural eles começam a se
preocupar com isso eles começam a ver
que o mundo é não vai conseguir
sustentar dessa maneira começa por se
preocupar com o meio ambiente
mas mesmo assim eles não fazem essa
ruptura essa ruptura só vai assinar na
geração dos nascidos entre 82 mil que a
geração y os milênios os milênios é uma
geração muito especial neto do milênio
se sente muito especial e ao mesmo tempo
parte de um todo
os milênios eles nascem mexendo no
iphone eles nascem mexendo no ipad
a internet está no dna dos milênios e
eles têm uma consciência ecológica e
social muito forte então todo milênio já
nasce preocupado com o desmatamento na
floresta amazônica
preocupado com a extinção dos pandas na
na ásia e preocupado com que tipo de
peixe tão dando pra baleia orca do
seaworld que só dá pelo letão uma
geração muito preocupada com essas três
gerações tiveram cada uma um impacto
muito forte na na agricultura
esse impacto aconteceu do mesmo jeito no
mundo inteiro mas eu vou focar aqui no
brasil
no brasil os baby boomers quando eles
tinham nos seus 30 40 anos
esses caras o o governo militar assumiu
é um golpe assumiu o poder
em 64 e uma grande preocupação do
governo militar era proteger suas
fronteiras e eles enviaram nada mais
barato do que envia um monte de
fazendeiro e um monte de de boiadeiro
pra ocupar essas áreas
e foi isso que que aconteceu os baby
boomers foram para o centro oeste norte
interior do nordeste e cultivaram boi
foi na frente e o progresso veio atrás
só que novamente na eles tinham a
preocupação de produzir e não tinham a
preocupação de preservar isso ainda num
mês destina o conceito de
sustentabilidade ainda não existia nessa
época quem começa de novo a questionar
isso ea gente está falando nos anos 90 e
2000 quando a geração x é começa a
assumir um papel de liderança eles
começam a questionar esse modelo foi
nessa época que o inpi se ganhou muita
força wwf ganhou força a essas ongs ea
globalização ela também globalizada
todas essas preocupações então estava o
mundo inteiro começou a ficar preocupada
com o desmatamento todos os olhos é
sobre o brasil que foi o último que
começou esse processo nem os outros
países já estavam todos desmatados e
isso começou a ficar á a ficar muito
evidentes mas de novo a geração x não
fez a ruptura
quem hoje a gente chega com uma geração
y com a seus 30 35 anos
a gente passou de 6 milhões de pessoas
atualmente estamos falando em 7 em 2025
esse número deve subir pra 8.2 milhões
de pessoas em 50 9 meio e em 2100 a
expectativa é que a gente tenha 12
bilhões de pessoas no mundo essa
população também é cada vez mais urbana
a gente teve uma um amplo crescimento aí
o êxodo rural principal
somente de índia e china nos últimos
anos então uma população cada vez mais
urbanizada essa taxa deve crescer deve
chegar a cerca de 80% em 2100 é uma
população cada vez também cada vez mais
consumista
esse modelo de consumo ele ele continua
ainda não foi rompido totalmente então
mais gente em mais cidade é mais tempo
na cidade e consumindo mais e o mundo
por outro lado continua o mesmo
a gente só tem um planeta terra e apesar
disso a pressão por preservação de
florestas aumentando essa que foi uma
passeata que levou 400 mil pessoas pra
em nova york é protestar contra o
aquecimento global então esse é um
conceito muito muito forte que está
muito enraizado essa preocupação com o
meio ambiente e essa equação ou esse
dilema entre é muita muita demanda é
muita gente só aumentando muito e a
mesma oferta é disso que vem ea o que os
pesquisadores eles calculam que hoje a
gente precisaria de três ou quatro
planetas terras pra gente continuar
sobrevivendo nesse modelo de consumo que
a gente tem hoje é três ou quatro
planetas terras eu só vejo dois tipos de
solução para a gente fugir desse
problema
o primeiro é a gente invadir um outro
planeta com as mesmas características
que o nosso
a gente viu no avatar isso não deu muito
certo e nem acha que vai acontecer num
futuro tão recente
o segundo ele tá muito ligado à o papel
de liderança da geração y de novo é uma
geração com foco muito em tecnologia e
em fazer
conexões essa geração y ela vai ter que
passar transformar esse dilema entre
produzir e preservar
para encontrar um equilíbrio entre
produção e preservação e isso é possível
de ser feito com muita tecnologia eu
mostrei aqueles casos ali no começo e
isso já existe só vai aumentar com muita
tecnologia e promovendo excelentes
histórias boas histórias produção de
maneira sustentável consumo de maneira
sustentável